someone called Leonardo DiCaprio there's
a bear that needs taming I'm Kate and
this is your gamespot news update suck
in 2014 nearly 4,000 people contributed
more than a hundred thousand dollars for
a game in which you would play as a bear
the game creatively titled bear
simulator was developed and finally
released in full just last month on
steam now it's developer john far j is
calling it quits announcing this week
that he's planning one more update than
walking away well the game didn't have a
great reception has a stigma against his
name and there's plenty of other
problems so making any updates or going
further is basically a lost cause now he
said in update to the game's kickstarter
page bardziej said he was hoping the
game steam release in February 2016
would go well but says it came up short
right now the game has a mostly positive
rating on the pc gaming platform however
far j said he maybe should have only
released it for backers and not through
steam according to kotaku youtube's
biggest star PewDiePie posted a less
than enthusiastic video about bear
simulator in which he gave the game
developer the finger after attempting to
get a steam refund for the video which
no longer appears to be available online
attracted more than 2.5 million views
one further update to bear simulator
will add Kickstarter Island and some
additional fixes bar jay says he plans
to continue to work on fixes as needed
but after that he will step away must be
doing this pc game dev thing wrong
because it is way too hard to stay happy
and productive he said the situation is
drawing comments from other industry
figures including Gears of War designer
cliff bleszinski what do you make of
this bear simulator situation let me
know in the comments or come and find me
on Twitter I'm at how not to draw thanks
for watching and for your gaming and
entertainment news keep it games box
you